bonjour je vous attendais aujourd'hui
pour vous raconter une histoire ont une
histoire que casimir a trouvé dans les
archives de l'île aux enfants
beaucoup d'entre vous ont écrit à
casimir pour lui demander son âge sont
d'ailleurs été bien déçu par sa réponse
parce que casimir ne connais absolument
pas son argent
j'ai moi même posé la question à
monsieur du snob et au facteur tout le
monde ignore l'âge de casimir ce que
nous avons quand même c'est que casimir
est un jeune cuisinier russe mais les
casimir us peuvent vivre si longtemps
que casimir ne sent pas un adulte c'est
à dire une grande personne avant avant
de nombreuses années
vous savez que l'on dit que dans la vie
d'un chien un nom correspond à 7 années
de la vie d'un homme
c'est à dire qu'un petit chien vieillira
ou grandir à cette fois plus vite qu'un
homme est bien en ce qui concerne les
casimir us monsieur du snob qui a
beaucoup étudié ce problème pense que
c'est l'inversé que en un nom c'est
l'homme qu'il ira cette fois plus vite
que le casimir us c'est à dire qu'un
casini russe pourrait vivre cette fois
plus longtemps qu'un homme c'est à dire
plusieurs centaines d'années ça je sais
bien qu'il faut toujours être très
prudent avec les théories de monsieur
10,9
mais l'histoire que je vous racontais
prouve à quel point les casimir us peut
vivre longtemps c'était en 13146 juste
au début de la guerre de cent ans les
anglais qui avaient décidé d'envahir le
territoire de l'île aux enfants en même
temps que le territoire de france venait
de battre les français à la bataille de
crécy noah d'angleterre alors envoyé à
deux de ses meilleurs généraux le 4 nov
du snob et le général khan crise
[Musique]
alors 6 aux plantes un champ de carottes
ici et la faim qui habite à l'autre bout
de l'île ne vont pas être contents si je
mets le sens là au milieu ça va déranger
les moutons c'est vraiment pas facile
alors monseigneur ya là deux gentilhomme
anglais qui désirent vouloir bien fait
les entrées je reviens dans un instant
[Musique]
un seigneur
leroy casimir et sa veille
il sera là dans un instant contre et
owendo
regardez c'est peut-être le plan de
défense de l'île aux enfants la chance
est avec nous il faudra en comprendre le
code à mon avis chaque lapin doit
correspondre à un bastion
[Musique]
l'euro mais seigneur bonjour je vois que
vous vous intéressez à mes problèmes de
carottes magistère beaucoup d'humour ou
d'autres langues et apprécions beaucoup
le mot
permettez nous de nous présenter à me
permettaient ces mineurs mais ça c'est
mon travail je faisais moi et le quantum
des snobs est la générale comme très
très bien alors à votre avis où
prendriez vous un champ de carottes
il est très fort et majesté que
représente cette sem moutons c'est la
fin question pertinente
ils représentent des moutons et des
lapins
il est vraiment très fort il va falloir
user majesté vous êtes ami de la france
et nous sommes en train de conquérir la
france
nous allons donc conquérir votre ville
pardonnez moi vous m'expliquerez ou la
russie n'a eu ce qu'il n'y a pas de ruz
vous êtes aussi très fort alors vous
êtes d'accord quoi pour conquérir mon
île c'est cela d'accord mais à une
condition que vous attendiez que je sois
mort et que la guerre dure moins de cent
ans
nous allons délibérer